[Music]
language dies like a backslide
hey youtubers we finally made it Game of
Thrones tonight these are going to be my
final death predictions just careful for
spoilers for everything that's happened
on the show so far the first episode is
airing later tonight so if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything
and turn alerts on so you don't miss any
of the videos I'll explain my video
schedule at the end of this but what I
tried to do for my death predictions
list is just stick to the main cast with
a couple guest stars because I do think
that the majority of the main cast will
survive the season eight and they'll
just start peeling cast members off
episode by episode those final six so
let's get right into it I just made this
a top 10 list and what I tried to do is
go from least likely to most likely so
there's some people that I'm pretty sure
are gonna die and then there's some
people that I'm definitely sure going to
die this season starting with number 10
at least one of the sand snakes in
probably ilaria sand that'd be the most
fitting because she was the architect of
the revenge against the Lannisters so in
the description for episode three Cersei
quote-unquote returns a gift if you
remember way back during season 4 she
got a gift of a necklace in a snake so
it sounds like she might return the gift
of a dead sand snake to Dorne
but I don't think that all the sand
snakes will die ol Arya feels like she'd
be the most impactful and Obara sand is
probably the most hardcore of all the
sand snakes if she survives it'd be a
good way for her to try and get revenge
in the final season although I don't
think that any of the sand snakes will
be successful in trying to kill Cersei
but number 9 beric Dondarrion so you'll
notice that a lot of the people and Jon
Snow's seeming group here to go north of
the wall or on this list at various
places there are so many reasons when
you look at these trailer shots why it
seems like beric Dondarrion is destined
to die because one he's getting ready
for what would be his seventh
resurrection if he dies again and
there's a lot of evidence pointing to
the fact that they're circling back
around to grab a big Lady Stoneheart
twist where he gives up his life to
resurrect another character in a sort of
breath of life situation where you give
someone mouth to mouth and literally
bring them back to life then you
consider all the fire white talk that
George R Martin was doing the other day
where he talked about how Barrack isn't
really alive he just a white WI ght
reanimated by fire instead of ice so he
doesn't have
blood flowing his veins his heart isn't
beating this scenario with then north of
the wall just feels completely
unwinnable which is why also number
eight Thoreau sub Mir is also on my list
thus far he's become a believer in his
time with beric Dondarrion his faith had
lapsed until beric Dondarrion died the
first time he prayed to the red God to
bring him back he came back it
henceforth he was a believer although
you look at him when he's talking to
Melisandre and he says he still doesn't
fully understand what's happening the
red God brings him back I just speak the
words but at this point he feels like
he's gotten super Opie like you could
just resurrect anyone on the spot so it
feels like they're going to yank the rug
out from under that in the Brotherhood
is nowhere near the wall in the books
right now so even though the TV show is
very different from the books they do
try to circle back around and grab big
plot points so I feel like the
Brotherhood north of the wall is all in
service of a big Lady Stoneheart style
twist but number seven at least one
member of Samwell Tarly 's family either
his father or his brother they recast
his brother Dickon Tarly and they're
implying that there's going to be a big
battle at Highgarden
his father is one of the greatest battle
commanders in Westeros killing him would
be a nice way to create some drama for
Samwell storyline in tension between him
and Daenerys and Rob Daenerys of a
potential really amazing battle
commander so remember how Robb Stark
executed Lord Karstark and what that did
later in the story in retaliation the
Karstarks later allied with the Bolton's
against Jon Snow so it'd be a fun way to
set up a big twist for Daenerys a
storyline where her overconfidence or a
misstep in her leadership bites her in
the ass much later in the story but
number six at least one of the Dragons
and if they're going to kill one off
obviously it's going to be one of the
younger ones I do think that Drogo is
going to make it to the end regardless
of what happens to the other dragons but
the way the writers talk about them
they're like nuclear weapons so you
balance the scales
by taking away one of Daenerys nukes
there's a number of ways that could
happen during the season of the two
dragons vissarion and Ragle that could
potentially die the Sirian would
probably be more meaningful because he's
named after her brother Viserys so it'd
be like her losing part of her family
even though the dragons are part of her
family I'd be like her Lu
using her brother again number five is
benjin I do feel like benjin will come
back and try to help when they go back
north of the wall it just feels like he
would be a really impactful of death but
not someone who's absolutely critical to
the final season there are only a couple
people that I think are going to walk
out of this situation here and even
though benjin is amazing in his sort of
half-turn state he's sort of half alive
it feels like he's going to fall in
service of Jon Snow's storyline the same
way that barrack and Thoros are so that
is why number four I feel like tormund
is also going to die too I know there's
a lot of people that are like wait a
minute he has to lead the wildlings it
would be really awesome if they tried to
marry him to a Lascar stark as a way to
sort of bind the loyalty of the
wildlings but it feels like Jon Snow
King crow has already won their loyalty
and I just keep going back to the idea
of this unwinnable scenario where
they're surrounded by whites in the
night King like torment is one of those
characters that you absolutely love it
would be heartbreaking to lose him but
unlike Jon Snow and Daenerys he's not
absolutely critical to the final season
if he falls they're still wildlings that
trust Jon Snow in faced with the
imminent threat of the army of the Dead
any objections that the people of the
north and the wildlings might have will
go away in season eight like this is
largely going to be resolved in the
first couple of episodes of season seven
you know they might argue a little bit
about the territory that they give to
the wildlings but by the end of the
season it's implied that everybody's
going to be on the same page holy crap
the army of the deads here we need to
put all of our differences aside and
that's what you would use torment for
like he would tell the wildlings to
follow Jon Snow and he's already done
that so he served his purpose number
three this is also pretty heartbreaking
Deloris edie in any of the Nights Watch
that are left at the wall when the night
king arrives if he arrives by the end of
the season it's always possible that
they end the season just a little bit
north as a wall but I do feel like the
season will begin and end on the wall so
we'll get like a final moment where
everybody feels like they're completely
screwed so if it doesn't happen at the
end of this season it's right at the
beginning of next season with the night
king rolling through with the army of
the Dead
and just washing over anybody that's
standing there at the gate at Castle
black my number two probably isn't a
surprise but I do feel like Jon Snow
will
fall again and they'll use that lady
stoneheart twist to bring him back where
barek and Thoros try to resurrect him it
doesn't work Barry gives his final life
when they're north of the wall to bring
him back and then he rides off on
benjin's horse because benjin has dead
he stayed behind here take my horse and
then he falls to the night king it just
feels like this horse is benjin's horse
and if benjin isn't riding on that horse
it means that he stayed behind and it
means that everybody else stayed behind
too but my number one you know big major
main character death prediction is a
little finger I feel like everything
about this lone wolf dies pack survives
is heading towards a team stark team up
to kill Littlefinger so the pack comes
together while little fingers trying to
sow dissent at Winterfell they get their
[ __ ] together and then take care of
Littlefinger because his entire season
for him isn't just trying to play the
Starks against each other they've been
teasing that Sansa might be a little bit
complicit but she's also slowly catching
on to his game so it sounds like she
will come to her senses in either she or
Arya will take care of him but I don't
think that it's going to happen while
Jon Snow is at Winterfell
like he's going to be spending most of
the latter half of the season in other
places if anybody's going to be left at
Winterfell it's going to be Arya and
Sansa and they've historically hated
each other so it sounds like they're
slowly going to come together and that
will be the moment that they take care
of Littlefinger
Cersei used to be on my list now but the
way that Lena Headey has been talking
about her just makes it sound like
they're allowing her to become the most
spectacularly evil insidious character
of the series the true villain when you
consider that the knight King is just
like this force of death he might be
evil incarnate but Cersei walks away
this year feeling like the true villain
of the series there are other characters
that I'm 50/50 on like Gendry the Queen
of thorns but let me know in the
comments who are your biggest death
predictions this season from the main
cast even the supporting characters but
after I post my episode 1 video tonight
we'll have to look back at the list and
see who got knocked off so what will
happen is I'll post my episode 1 video
after it airs it should be up by 9 p.m.
Pacific time you can follow me on
Twitter and Facebook there is a new
round of the giveaway all you have to do
to enter is just be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video
congratulations to last
winner Joshua Cox please private message
me so I can get your contact details
I'll just remind everybody about the
giveaway when I post my episode 1 video
tonight but why you wait for everything
you can click here for my episode 1
preview and you can click here for all
my other season 7 videos thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight